hi how are you how are you good how are
you i'm good thank you my first red
carpet in three years no way how are you
going to make it good uh oh boy that's a
lot of pressure cheryl i do not want to
screw this up for you i know that you
vacation hard as well so like this i
come on a vacation for you coming into
work i know i am um wow yeah zooms are
yeah zooms are hard to get over it's
like breaking an addiction
but i'm so glad that we did i know yeah
it's nice to be in person this movie is
fantastic
which makes me want to ask you what
would you say to your younger self and
in turn what would you say to your older
self
oh boy uh i don't know what i would say
to my younger self i mean
i've always i think i would try to be a
little bit more compassionate i've
always been pretty self-loathing that's
sort of what we tackle in the movie is
that you think when i meet my younger
self i'm going to be this sweet generous
like caring person but i'm actually just
the opposite i'm a kind of a dick to him
um so you know if i saw my younger self
i'd probably be like hey you're gonna
you know you're gonna be like a
certifiable [ __ ] until you're about 35
years old but then you're gonna get it
together and then things are gonna go
really really well yeah things are gonna
be okay yeah you know yeah this movie's
like a cross between i've heard people
say et and star wars
but a real movie for families i mean
you've got free guy that families can go
see families can come and see this
why is that important to you to make
movies like this right now it's it's i
don't know if it's important as much as
i just feel so lucky that both sean levy
and i who we did free guy together as
well we co-produced it together and then
this one is the same sort of situation
that we get to tell these big
you know
wish fulfillment spectacle driven kinds
of movies that also have something quite
personal and intimate at their core and
it is a kind of
style of movie-making that amblin
perfected so beautifully in the 80s with
et with you know even stand by me and
back to the future and goonies and you
know i just it's it feels like it's a
great time for a movie like this it felt
like that was free guy as well it was
just sort of we needed a little fastball
of joy and we got it and you know so i i
i this movie is really special to me i
know it is for sean as well and it's
legally killing him like he may be dead
right now that he's missing this in
toronto because he's in budapest of
shooting another movie well i remember
cheating on me okay i remember one time
you said you were going to take a break
you wanted to be home with the family
and to chill out so is the reason the
back-to-back movies because blake wants
you out of the house or because shawn's
just so good like i know my husband and
i have like sometimes i'm like i think
you should go do you
no you know when we shoot something it's
a family affair we all go i love that uh
you know when blake shoots something i i
we all go i go i'm not shooting anything
when i'm shooting something she's the
same way so so it's it's always kind of
a family fair but this one really was
because of sean and this is kind of what
a sabbatical looks like for me i'm not
away shooting anywhere i'm basically
home every day i have a lot of work to
do but that work i get to do from home
so i get to walk the kids to school and
bring them home at night it's just you
know it's it's how it should be
lastly you made me incredibly unpopular
with my son when i said no to deadpool
so could you tell jackson why i'm a good
parent he's upstairs now and that he's
watching this tonight why am a good
parent that i made that rule
because i think this is the only way
we're going to get past this jackson
your mom is the greatest and you know
something what you're watching tonight
the adam project is kind of a love
letter to parents it seems like a big
time travel movie with a whole bunch of
science fiction and fun in it but it's
actually a trojan horse we're smuggling
a little love story to your mom
thank you there i think that's been
settled now perfect thank you so much